- Hi everyone.
I'm Maurice Samuels, the
Director of the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism,
and on behalf of YPSA and the
Whitney Humanities Center,
it's my great pleasure to welcome you
to the first event of our
Benjamin and Barbara Zucker
webinar lecture series this
year, which will be devoted
to exploring the
relationship of antisemitism
to anti-Blackness and
other forms of prejudice.
We have a superb lineup
of speakers planned,
who will guide us in a
conversation about the challenges
that Jews, Blacks, Asians, Muslims,
and other minorities face in common,
and about the differences that divide us.
Please make sure to sign
up for our mailing list
on the website for the Yale Program
for the Study of Antisemitism,
so you receive our webinar invitations
and feel free to publicize
these far and wide.
Just a few words before we get started
about how the event today will work.
Our speakers will talk
for about 30 minutes,
at which point they will
start taking questions
from the audience.
Please submit your questions
anytime during the presentation
using the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen.
They will only be visible to me
and I will submit them to speakers.
The chat function is disabled.
The audience will also remain
muted throughout the event
and we'll finish around 6:00 PM.
So it's my great pleasure to
introduce today's speakers.
First, Anthony Russell, here
he is, is a vocalist, composer
and arranger specializing in
music in the Yiddish language.
This work has brought him to
Los Angeles, Philadelphia,
Boston, Miami, New York,
Toronto, Montreal, London,
Berlin, Copenhagen,
Warsaw, Krakow, Tel Aviv,
Symphony Space in New York City
and the Kennedy Center in Washington DC.
Anthony's work with the Klezmer trio,
Veretski Pass, resulted in "Convergence,"
an EP exploring a century
of African-American
and Ashkenazi Jewish music.
Anthony lives in Massachusetts
with his husband,
Rabbi Michael Rothbaum.
Next, we have Jeff Melnick.
Here's Jeff.
Jeff teaches American Studies
at the University of Massachusetts Boston,
where he spends a fairly
large percentage of his time
these days on his work as a member
of the Faculty Staff
Union Executive Committee.
In his scholarly life, he
has written a number of books
including two in the arena
of Black-Jewish relations,
"A Right to Sing the Blues:
"African-Americans, Jews
and American Popular Song,"
and "Black-Jewish Relations on Trial:
"Leo Frank and Jim
Conley in the New South."
Most recently, he published
"Creepy Crawling with the Manson Family,"
a cultural history of
the legacies of Manson
and his followers.
At present, Jeff is
researching a book on race
and youth culture in Boston
in the years following
public school integration in the 1970s.
I'm extremely grateful
to both Anthony and Jeff
for helping us launch
our series and the title
of their discussion today
is "Shifting Affinities:
Cultural Investigation
"of the Black-Jewish Relations Paradigm."
So I will now hand it
over to Jeff and Anthony.
- First, I think I'd like to
establish my own observations
of certain underlying dynamics
of the American Black-Jewish
relations paradigm,
namely cultural rhetoric of
trans-historical connection
that imbues so many
discussions of the relationship
between Black and Jewish
populations in American space.
I feel like it's an underexamined
historical circumstance
that specifically, two disparate
diasporas happened to meet
on American soil, and of
course not just the diasporas,
but the general rhetorical baggage,
each of those diasporic identities entail
concerning loss of homeland, peoplehood,
prophetic narratives,
concepts of redemption
and freedom and the like.
With specifically Biblical
cultural rhetoric,
as far as Black people are concerned,
I've encountered certain
Jewish interlocutors
who call this phenomenon an appropriation,
which I think is a misguided
term, in this case,
as Jewish text and narrative tropes
were originally imposed
on enslaved Black people
under duress as a part
of the hegemonic dictates
of colonial Christianity.
I do feel that it is very much in keeping
with the general ways of
being Black in the world,
that something that was
imposed on Black people
as an establishment of
order was summarily turned
into an article of
self-determination and freedom,
but that's a whole other
conversation for another day.
Coming from the Jewish
side, in the Magid section
of the Passover Haggadah
is the following statement.
"Whoever expounds on
the story of the Exodus
"at length is worthy of praise."
So there is, of course
a Halakhic dimension
to this statement.
The mitzvah is not merely
in knowing about the Exodus,
but also in speaking about it,
and expounding upon that narrative.
So I'd like to make the
contention that perhaps,
when Jews encounter the phenomenon
of formerly enslaved people
in the United States,
culturally, rhetorically
there was this quality
of Black people as living expositions
of the Exodus narrative.
Because of that, Black
people have become a site
of Jewish projection, identification,
and even, perhaps,
naturalization of historical
Jewish suffering on the American soil.
Rhetorically, Black people almost exist
as an atavistic enactor
of nascent peoplehood
after the ravages of systemic oppression,
a narrative most famously
sketched out, of course,
in the Exodus narrative itself.
I think this is partly why
facile and reductive comparisons
of the respective
socioeconomic trajectories
of Black and Jewish people are invoked,
oftentimes by Jewish critics,
because there's this
preexisting notion that somehow,
these two groups of people
are somehow intrinsically related,
even when their respective outcomes
are diametrically opposed.
This is spelled out much
more explicitly, I think,
when we look at the history
of Black cultural expression
and genre consumed and eventually,
produced as extensions
of Jewish expression
as a sort of cultural rhetorical space
of establishing both
the Jewish connection,
and very importantly, Jewish
distance from Black people
in American social and cultural space.
And I'm very lucky to
be talking to Jeffrey
because this is something about which
he has written about quite ably.
- Amazing.
So I'll, I'll jump in there.
And first of all, thank
Anthony for being the one
to kick this off.
Thank everyone at Yale who organized this
and thank all of you who we can't see,
but are so grateful are joining
us for this conversation.
So, you know, this is like
probably a kind of standard move
to make, but one of the
things I always try to do
when I talk about Black-Jewish
relations is sort of start,
and Anthony's already
begun this conversation,
open up this question
about what we mean when
we use that phrase.
And something I tried to do
early in my career is replace
the phrase with a different phrase,
which, of course, couldn't possibly work.
The different phrase I wanted to introduce
was Black-Jewish relatedness,
as opposed to Black-Jewish relations,
because there's a conflation that happens,
and Anthony, as I said,
Anthony has already begun
to lay this out for you.
There's a conflation that happens
between two very different things.
One is actual interaction,
is between Black people
and Jewish people.
And then, of course, we
have to confront the fact
that there are Black Jewish people.
So there's the actual
meetings between Black people
and Jewish people in the United States
in this overdetermined way
that Anthony has already
illumined for you.
And then there's the kind
of cultural imaginary,
that all the work we do
to construct the idea
that somehow Black
people and Jewish people
share some really
consequential similarities.
Now let me just start with
Black-Jewish relations,
because that's a phrase that
I think most of the people
who are on this call
probably are familiar with.
You wouldn't have come
to a talk like this,
if you didn't know that
Black-Jewish relations is a thing,
and had some weight in
American cultural history
and political history and
economic history, legal history.
But it wasn't always a
thing with that name.
And so one of the things
I wanna do is sort of,
is just kind of unpack
that name a little bit,
Black-Jewish relations,
because my sense is
that we don't really have
that as a common phrase,
as a way of talking about
these actual interactions
until the 1950s or 1960s.
I mean, it gets going in the 1950s,
but it really kicks off in the 1960s.
And one of the interesting things to note
is that they take off
because there's a sense
that develops, particularly amongst
certain well-placed Jewish people,
that the relationship is falling apart.
So there's a number of things
that happened in the 1960s.
And I won't, you know, I don't
wanna create a whole archive
of this now in the limited
time we have together,
but I'll say a few obvious things.
There's a sort of clear recognition
that the kinds of alliances that brought
African-Americans and Jews
together in the world,
of the popular culture, in
the world of jurisprudence,
legal work, those things weren't happening
with the depth and the
rapidity and the constancy
that they had happened in,
as had happened in the 1930s
and '40s, early 1950s.
So there's this, there's a few crises
that happen in the 1960s.
I'll just locate one for now.
The Ocean Hill Brownsville
School Crisis of the 1960s,
where Black parents were
trying to gain control
of their local schools
and the teacher's union.
And I can't believe I'm about
to say something critical
of the teacher's union, now
that Mauri introduced me
as centering my own
teacher's union as crucial
to my work in the world right now,
but the teacher's union, which was,
had a Jewish leader and a
very, a large population
of Jewish teachers really resisted this,
because this felt like an incursion
on their professional
control of the schools.
And it got ugly in a
number of different ways,
and I don't want to go into
all the details of that,
but one of the things that
grew out of that event
and a number of other moments of that kind
of direct conflict were
symposiums and lectures
and books and editorials,
and hand-wringing.
I mean, more than anything hand-wringing,
and just about every
one of these symposiums,
symposium and lectures
was called something
like "What Went Wrong," right?
It always had that kind
of logic of inevitability
built into it, right,
that the relationship
between African-Americans
and Jews was somehow natural.
So that brings me to the relatedness part,
because the naturalness
was not necessarily baked
into the actual interactions,
the naturalness was baked
into this sense of, and again,
I'm referring to Anthony's
initial commentary,
the naturalness is built
into this sense that somehow,
Blacks and Jews are deeply
similar to each other.
And it has its roots,
obviously in this 19th century,
African-American adoption of
certain sacred Jewish texts,
but it also has 20th
century iterations, right?
It had the sense that
African-Americans and Jews
are the most musical people
in the United States,
that African-Americans and
Jews are the most likely,
most likely groups to be
fighting for social justice
in the United States.
So this thing that I'm
calling the cultural imaginary
developed, which tells us that more
than any other nonwhite groups,
and I'm using that word nonwhite
really advisedly now,
and in a contingent way,
and only really up until the early 1930s,
the sense that African-Americans and Jews
are the two nonwhite
groups sort of most likely
to find each other and work together,
whether it's in the music industry
or the Civil Rights
Movement creates sort of,
on top of it, this super
structure of relatedness, right?
And so, I really tried to push this idea
that there's a relatedness
that's different
from the actual relations.
Now, the problem, and I'm
gonna stop at it for now,
I'm gonna stop after I
say this one last thing
is that it comes, there comes
a moment where the relations
break down enough that the relatedness
comes into question, as well.
And I'll timestamp that sometime
late 1960s, early 1970s.
And we'll say that
there's this other thing
that happens that we'll
need to talk about,
which is that up until the
1950s, African-Americans and Jews
tended to live really close to each other.
I'm sitting here in Boston.
So I'm thinking about Roxbury, Mattapan.
I know a lot of you are
sitting in New Haven.
So if you think about the closeness of,
let me see if I get this
right, I'm trying to remember,
Westville to Newhallville,
neighborhoods in New Haven,
which are largely Jewish,
largely African-American.
If you think about New York, you know,
thinking about Harlem and the succession
of African-Americans
coming up through Jews,
and there is this very
sort of every day contact
that African-American and Jews have,
which kind of supports
this idea of relatedness,
but that really begins
to end in the 1950s,
as Jews take part in what we
have to call White Flight.
And Jews who are living in
urban areas like Roxbury
and like Harlem and, you know,
sort of pick your neighborhood,
in the city that you're interested in,
they're not there anymore.
They leave traces behind
because they still are involved
in businesses in those places,
and that makes things
even more complicated,
that the Jewish presence in
a lot of that neighborhood
is now simply as
merchants or as landlords.
And that makes it really
complicated to imagine
that Africans-Americans and
Jews are simply together,
the same, alike.
So I'm gonna step back
there and see if Anthony
wants to jump back in.
Muted again.
It looks like they're
unmuting us one at a time.
Yeah, yeah.
- Got it.
So this concept of an inherent relatedness
becomes endlessly
complicated and problematic
when one examines, how much
agency Black people have had
in this rhetorical relationship,
and how much material good
this relationship has
actually rendered them.
It becomes really problematic
when one considers
how these narratives of connection
so easily become a platform for concrete
and established recrimination.
Whenever Black people fell outside
of the invisible boundaries
of what is supposed to be
a familial connection, the pain
and the feelings of betrayal
that arise in the hearts
of Jewish observers
of patterns of antisemitic thinking
in parts of the Black community,
I think these feelings
of betrayal are familial,
actually, in nature.
How can you, a version of
myself, indulge in thinking
that potentially undermines yourself,
rather you as a version of myself?
And I think this unusual
kind of, I think you said
a cultural imaginary sort
of relationship imbues a lot
of the rhetoric that the
monolithic Jewish community
has in relationship to the
monolithic Black community,
but not always vice versa.
I'm willing to bet
Jeffrey is probably trying
to unmute himself at the moment.
- Yeah, and I don't, and
I don't wanna put anyone
on the spot here, but if you're saying,
we're gonna try to actually
have a conversation,
so if there's any times
we can both be on the mic
at the same time, it looks
like maybe we are now.
That'd be great, thank you so much.
So yeah, I wanna pick up on
the last thing Anthony said
and run with it a little bit,
this idea, and it brings us,
obviously, to the title of this seminar
and the purpose of our visit today,
this idea that there's
a very particular kind
of Black antisemitism is a
question that I think Anthony
and I both, you know, sort of wrestle with
in our conversations and
our thinking about this.
And I think he said
something really important.
I just wanna underscore it and
maybe extend it a little bit.
The idea that if there's
any Black disagreement
or Black distance from
a Jewish organization
or a Jewish movement
or a Jewish production
that that's seen as a kind of betrayal
and not just distance, disinterest.
Agency is the word Anthony used,
and that seems perfect.
And so there is this problem
with Black-Jewish relations,
as it's usually constituted, which is,
and this is really tricky to talk about.
I wanna paraphrase something
Adolph Reed wrote in his book
about Jesse Jackson,
because Jesse Jackson,
of course, he's one of those
kinds of African-Americans who,
when he did something that was construed,
and I don't necessarily want to relitigate
that whole case but like when
he when he said Hymietown,
and there was this question
about whether Jesse Jackson
was antisemitic, there was, this went on,
this conversation went on for years,
and the question that some
Jews finally got to was,
does it really show, the
face that he even knows
the word Hymie, as a slur of Jews,
does it show that somehow,
he really is family,
that he is in close, right?
Because that, right, and so
one of the things Adolph Reed
underscored in his book
about Jesse Jackson,
in one chapter where he was talking
about the sort of Black
antisemitism question
is that one of the problems
with Black-Jewish relations
is that very often, it's a conversation
that white Jewish people want to steer
from both sides, right?
They wanna say their piece,
but they also want someone
who will wanna ventriloquize
what African-Americans should
be saying and doing, right?
There's the agency question again.
And so I'm really, it's really
uncomfortable to talk about
because it does play into some,
it does play into some bad,
the analysis of this plays into some bad
old antisemitic images of Jews as,
well Jews as puppetmasters, you know,
sort of controlling the
discourse, the Svengali,
you know, kind of construct
but it's a really important
question to ask, right?
Because one of the things
that, in Black-Jewish relations
we always talk about
is that Jews were there
for African-Americans,
they were there at the
founding of the NAACP.
They were there on the legal team,
in the Brown vs. Board of Ed discussion.
They were there, obviously in, in the,
enrolling voters drive in
Mississippi in 1964, right?
These are sacred texts of
Black-Jewish relations,
and one of the problems
with the way we talk
about that whole history is
that it becomes impossible
to figure out where sort
of the Jewish contribution
begins and ends, because
it becomes a sort of like,
it becomes the water, yeah.
- It's a communal property.
It becomes a communal property.
- Perfect, yeah, yeah.
- And it's...
It's a problematic communal property,
because what it does is
it conflates the actions
of a statistically small amount
of very grave individuals
who decided to actually
move against the tide
of where American, the
American Jewish community
was socially, and to show
up on behalf of Black people
for the purpose of racial equality,
and what has happened, of
course, in the intervening years
is that their actions have been conflated
with the entire American Jewish community.
And what that has created is a rhetoric
of indebtedness that Black people have
in relationship to the Jewish community.
And I think it's really
important for me to say.
and for people to hear that
this is an unfortunate platform
on which to build any sort of solidarity
around the issues of antisemitism
and acting on anti-Blackness.
- Right.
- Black people
in the United States already
have and continue to have
a very unfortunate experience
with rhetorics of indebtedness.
You'll see this crop up
in any number of spaces
where people have decided that actually,
it was a good thing that
entire populations of Africans
were brought to the United States,
because pick your period.
They found Jesus, that
would be a very 19th century
sort of version of that idea.
Maybe later, they became
acquainted with Western society
and culture to their benefit.
You can go on Twitter right now,
and find somebody who's probably saying
something to this degree.
If you hadn't come to the United States,
you would be in Ethiopia
and you'd be starving,
or you would be a child soldier.
Given that so much of the
rhetoric around Black people
in the United States has come
from a place of indebtedness,
a rhetorics, and a
politics of indebtedness
in relationship to a
response to antisemitism
is undermining and is not sustainable
and does not build the kind of solidarity
that is needed to arrest
patterns of antisemitic thinking
in the Black community, if I
could talk about a community
in a complete monolith, and
the way that one almost has to
in these kinds of conversations
- Right. That's brilliant, yeah.
I mean, just the very familiarity we have
with the phrase Black antisemitism,
you know, James Baldwin
decades ago, 50 years ago,
was trying to remind us that you know,
if Black people are antisemitic,
it's because they're
anti-white and that's something
just like a lot of Jews
don't like to hear, right?
'Cause it upsets a
certain Jewish narrative
of marginalization, of
kind of special kind
of community place
that's not purely white,
but that indebtedness is a real problem
because it plunges us, all of us,
into these situations where Black people,
in this very ritual, narrow,
ritualized narrow way,
where Black people are sort
of urged, you know, pushed,
encouraged, pick your verb, to apologize
for other Black people,
for bad Black people.
And that's a really bad ritual
that I think we really need
to sort of think harder about, right?
And this comes up, you know,
I'm old enough that I feel
like I can sort of track
cycles of every five years,
some mainstream Black leader
has to disavow Louis Farrakhan.
And it's like, you know, that's something
we need to get past, right?
'Cause Louis Farrakhan
is really important,
has a lot of followers, but he just,
he's not at the heart of
mainstream Black experience
in the United States.
- Good luck trying to
make that case, though.
I think there are people in
the American Jewish community
who think we have pictures
of Farrakhan on the wall.
Like he's the Lubavitcher
Rebbe, and it's not like that.
I think there are spaces
in the Black community
in which his leadership is
looked on with a certain amount
of dubiousness and derision.
It's, I have a lot of
problems with kind of,
in the formation and mobilization
of a monolithic concept
like Black antisemitism,
because I don't think it's helpful
or particularly effective
against fighting patterns
of antisemitic thinking in
parts of the Black community.
Establishing a phenomenon of
antisemitism in ethnic terms
gives it the dimensions of
something that is intrinsic
to that ethnicity, as if
in each Black person lurks
an innate antisemite, who
must be tamed, exorcized
and denounced.
- Right.
- The concept of Black antisemitism
makes antisemitism not into an idea
or a prominent person or
persons who is disseminating
these ideas among the Black community,
but rather it turns patterns
of antisemitic thinking
into an amorphous phenomenon, which,
while rhetorically useful,
actually undermines the
potential to address
and dismantle patterns
of antisemitic thinking.
Black antisemitism is much
more useful as a phrase
and as a rhetorical
device than it is as a way
of actually fighting patterns
of antisemitic thinking.
- That's right, that's right.
And I mean, just for our purposes today,
to try to start focusing on this thing
we call Black-Jewish relations,
I was thinking back to moments in my own
sort of scholarly life when
when there were these eruptions
of mourning of worry about
Black-Jewish relations,
about Black antisemitism
and one of the major ones
that I'm sure many people
on this call remember
were the Crown Heights
Riots of 1991, which again,
without getting into
the granular details of,
brought into conflict Hasids
and a Black community in Brooklyn
that was largely West Indian, right?
And that came to stand for,
in this synecdochical way,
I forgot that word, right
for all of Black-Jewish relations,
two very marginal communities
for each group, right?
West Indian, mostly immigrant population,
who came to stand for
Black people in the U.S.
And Hasids, who came to stand for Jews.
Hasids have not been in the
Black-Jewish relations game,
you know, that we've been outlining
for this history, right?
Like they just get pulled
on into that narrative
in that moment because
they're sort of visible,
obviously visibly Jewish,
and that's something,
you know, as a historian,
I always wanna try
to bring to the table and say like,
when we're talking about
Black-Jewish relations,
at least let us try to specify.
And Anthony was trying to do that before,
when he was sort of reminding us
that it's a very small percentage,
a particular kind of politically
engaged Jewish people
who have been involved
in that main, you know,
sort of historical activity
of civil rights work.
It's a very small group of Jewish people
who were involved with the certainly,
you know, the key legal cases
of the late '40s, early '50s.
So that's the thing I
want to remind us of,
is to sort of think about
who we're trying to catch
in this net when we cast this net
called Black-Jewish relations
- I'd like to bring up
the fact that usually,
in evocations of the Golden
Age of Black-Jewish relations,
of course, Rabbi Abraham Joshua Heschel
always makes a starring appearance.
I've had the virtue and the pleasure
of knowing his daughter, Susanna Heschel,
who is an amazing scholar
and over Shabbos dinner,
we were talking about this very subject.
And she said very directly,
that if you aren't doing
the work of creating racial
justice in this country,
you don't get to name check her father,
which means that a lot of
rhetoric that has been created
around this issue would
instantaneously disappear,
because oftentimes, this
affinity that these two groups
have for each other is
often expressed in terms
that are either approaching
or have surpassed the half century mark.
What do you do with an affinity
when it's about two generations back?
- Right.
That's a great question.
I just wanna note, and I don't
know if it's time or not,
that we're a little past 5:30,
and I don't know if
there's questions coming up
in the chat yet, 'cause it's hard for me
to see where they are.
And I know that Anthony
and I can keep going until
somebody says end meeting,
but I also wanna make sure
that we're going to leave
enough time for other people
to get into the conversation.
- [Mauri] You guys can,
this is Mauri talking,
you guys can keep going
for a little while longer
and then I'll jump in.
- Okay, you'll jump in, okay, great.
Okay, just wanted to check on that.
So, you know, one of the things I'm gonna,
I want to put another
term into the conversation
that I feel like we've
been dancing around,
but haven't quite said, which is class,
and we're not gonna be able to have
a forthright conversation
about this thing called,
so-called Black antisemitism
or Black-Jewish relations
more generally without talking
about the very different class
trajectories of white Jews
and African-Americans in
the United States, right?
Maybe it goes without saying,
but it's one of things
I was trying to index
when I talked a little bit
about white flight, which
is this, this period
and this formation that we
try to capture with this name,
Black-Jewish relations is
really rooted in this time
when Americans Jews were city people,
and were sort of working
class to lower middle class.
And we're in this moment now
where the class differential
between white Jews and African-Americans
in the United States is so stark
that it's almost impossible
to sort of have the conversation
without at least noting
that the two communities, it's
more than two communities,
obviously, but for the shorthand,
two communities are living
literally living in very different places.
They're occupying very
different vocations.
I know I'm painting with a very broad,
in very broad strokes right now,
but, but there is, and I feel like Anthony
was sort of outlining
this a little bit before,
this idea that Blacks and
Jews aren't so different
from each other, and not only
are they not so different,
but there's this kind of
like amazing cultural energy
that convinces us that
they're almost the same,
and that's really dangerous, to my mind.
It makes it impossible
for African-Americans
to kind of find good
spaces in U.S. culture,
as speaking subjects,
telling their own stories,
and not telling a story
that that's kind of like,
that we always, that we know already
that's already been scripted.
- I think it's very easy
to kind of want to...
It's very easy for people
to want to have a discussion
about Jews in the United States
and the relationship to assimilation
into greater American culture,
but I think what is not
often discussed is that,
in order to do that,
there was a preexisting racial hierarchy
that either had to be
passively or actively accepted
as almost the fare for kind of arriving
into full American assimilation,
and a lack of engagement with that,
I think, as a community, or
really, with that as an idea,
once again, undermines the ability
for these two communities, so I can speak
about these two people and in a monolith
like we have to throughout
this conversation,
it undermines the ability for us to have
a historically honest conversation
about where we have been
and where we could possibly go as far
as joining each other
in the work of creating
racial equality in this country.
- Right.
- Okay, I'm gonna jump in here,
'cause we do have a bunch
of questions from people.
And I would just ask, I
noticed that some people
have raised their hand, but
since I can't call on people,
if you could type your
questions in the Q&A,
so if you see that little
Q&A button at the bottom,
you can type questions there,
and I will ask the panelists.
So we have a bunch of questions.
This is really such a
fascinating conversation,
and I think we're all just
so grateful to both of you
for your thoughtfulness
about these issues.
So one question that I
had, and that I see also
that some of the people
in the audience have had
is I think people were a
little bit puzzled by something
you said, Jeff, about how
Jews weren't really white
until the 1930s, or maybe
weren't seen as white.
And we're wondering if you
could just say something
about how Jews became white.
Did Black people ever
not see Jews as white?
Did...
You know, how do we parse
this idea of Jews as almost white
but not quite white
enough for white America?
- Mm-hmm, great, yeah, that's,
thank you anybody who's
thinking about that
and asking the question.
Thank you, Mauri, for
putting it on the table.
You know, Jewish whiteness
is a really complex,
historical question.
I've written about it, I see
at least two other people
on the call who have written about it,
as I scroll down, and I'm
sure, probably more some folks
who maybe, I don't know.
So this is something that historians
really got interested in, 1980s, 1990s,
definitely earlier, as well.
And, there's this sort of
clear sense that at least
up until the 1920s, Jews occupied
some kind of middle space.
Jews are not the only not sort
of distinct group in the U.S.
We've got great historians
of Italian-American life,
great historians of, you
know, Armenian-American life
who have tried to parse this question.
Now, what do we do about
these groups that immigrated
as part of the Great Wave
starting in the 1880s,
so what we'd generally
call the New Immigration,
and were not Anglo-American?
And Jews were clearly part of that,
Eastern European Jews, in particular,
the German Jews who came earlier,
a little bit of a different story
but Eastern European Jews were seen,
were definitely seen as
a distinct population.
Up through the '20s, there
was plenty of people,
anthropologists, politicians, journalists,
who were still referring
to Jews as a race, right?
That's obviously like not an
understanding that we have now
of Jews, and the process
by which Jews stopped
being publicly recognized as a race,
it's obviously not overnight.
We can't put a year on it.
We can, you know, make a,
we can put some frames around it, right?
We can certainly say
that by the 1930s, 1940s,
as Jews are sort of moving
up the economic ladder,
certainly as news of
the genocide in Europe
starts making its way to the
United States, in the 1950s,
it kind of helps frame
this idea that Jews need
to be sort of like, we need to underscore
the safety of Jews in the United States.
And part of the safety
is understanding Jews
as white people, and then really, I think,
with the suburbanization of the 1950s,
it becomes impossible to think of Jews
as anything other than, just another,
what, in the 1960s and '70s,
we start more frequently referring
to as an ethnic group, right?
And so Jews are like
Italians, or like Irish
or like various other hyphenated groups
that are clearly white.
You know, this holds for
immigrant groups up until,
basically 1965, when the
immigration law changes.
And there's a huge wave of
people from Latin America,
Asia, the Caribbean, Africa, and so on,
who are hyphenated Americans
and clearly not white
in American terms.
So that's a quick answer.
I could go on, but yeah.
- No, that's great.
That's...
Another question from someone is how,
someone who grew up in
the South and is you know,
wondering about whether we
can say the Jews in the South
adopted the prejudice of
white non-Jewish southerners.
And so I think we can say, you know,
where most Jews came from,
they probably didn't have many opinions
of Black people at all.
And so how did, can we
trace that kind of history
of anti-Black prejudice among Jews?
How would we tell that story?
- In the historical record,
you find many proofs
of a general amount of bafflement
from the Southern Jewish
community in the face
of all of these Northerners
who came over the course
of Mississippi Summer,
because to a certain extent,
they had already figured out,
in decades and centuries previous,
what their specific place
was in the racial hierarchy
of the American South.
And they knew that that
level of interaction
with Black people put that in peril.
So there is that, I mean, that is a part
of the historical record
is that all of these,
you know, Jews from the North
came and the Jews in the South
were like, who are these people?
What are they doing? What is this about?
- [Jeff] Right, right.
- And I should just say actually,
one of the people in the
audience pointed out that,
of course you know, white people,
or Jews have had the privilege of choosing
whether to be white to a certain extent,
you know, and whether to do that,
which is an interesting...
So here's another question
from the audience.
What about the role of Black Jews?
And this is something,
maybe a question, Anthony,
so, you know, we have,
of course, you know,
the kind of celebrity examples
like Sammy Davis, Jr.,
but also, you know, there,
maybe more problematically,
the Black Israelite movement
and things like that.
How should we think about those groups?
A question, really, for both of you.
- I think as far as Black
Israelites are concerned,
it's complicated because
in that case, it really is,
I think quite directly, an appropriation
of Jewish religiosity, as a
form of religious expression.
And I think there's a
lot of different aspects
of Black diasporic history that
go into that sort of impulse
to appropriate very directly,
this way of expressing
one's self religiously.
It's very hard for me
to actually figure out
how that fits in, and it's
something about which I'm afraid,
I'm a little ignorant.
It's something that I've been
meaning to learn more about,
just because it's interesting in general,
but I don't know.
In a way it seems like...
A sort of fulfillment, an
embodiment of this idea
of the paradigm, but it goes off into such
a very definitive direction that I think,
in many ways, if they're not
looked on with hostility,
they're looked on with a
great amount of curiosity
as a bizarity in relationship
to the normative aspects
of American Judaism.
- Right.
And I'll just throw in
that obviously mainstream,
white Jews are not particularly interested
in Black Jews of any kind.
There's not like a huge
community outreach effort
to bring, to open up conversations
with the more fringe groups
or to bring in, and
that's part, obviously,
of Jewish, Jews not being
the converting people,
but you know, that's there too.
I mean, there there's, I just
wanna just quickly go back
to the question about Jews in the South,
since I have particular interest
there, in an earlier era
then than what Anthony was talking about,
which is that most of
the Jews in the South
in the pre-World War
II era are German Jews.
And they're, to borrow a word
that they wouldn't have used,
'cause it's a more Eastern
European, Yiddish kind of word,
they were alrightniks.
I mean, they were really
satisfied with their position
by and large, as quasi-white people,
or apprentice white people.
And that's a really, that made
for really complicated math
in moments of crisis when, you know,
and obviously I wrote a book about it,
the Leo Frank case.
So that's a moment of real crisis,
where Jews make great
efforts to try to demonstrate
to the white people around them,
that they are really
better than Black people,
and really more trustworthy
and safer and all that.
Yeah.
- Of course, there's also,
the Israeli dimension
to this question, which I don't think
we wanna get into today, but of course,
Jews have gone to Israel,
and you see that there are
a lot of Jews from Ethiopia.
They are not, obviously,
it's a whole other,
and so, here's a question
for Jeff, from Matt Jacobson,
who's written a lot about these questions,
and he wants to know, how,
he says that the idea
of Black antisemitism
really controlled the space of the 1990s.
And, but here we are in this
very different moment in 2020,
in a moment of kind of
frank, white nationalism,
and we really have no narrative
to suture these moments together.
Can you kind of maybe try to do that,
or maybe narrate your
own position in relation
to these two moments as a scholar?
- That's great.
I mean, thanks, Matt, for the question.
And I'd like to bring,
you know, Anthony in
on answering it too, 'cause
that's sort of recent history
that we're both trying to parse right now.
And still, the sort of overfamiliarity,
and as you were asking,
I was trying to remember
who the celebrity was who
had to go through recently,
this ritual of apologizing
and he's teamed up
with some rabbi who's teaching him
how to really understand Jews,
and I'm blanking on who
it was now. You got it?
- It's Nick Cannon.
- Nick Cannon, of course, right?
And so we still have
this ritual of, you know,
a Black person saying
something and I don't remember
what Nick Cannon said,
and it was maybe awful,
I don't remember, but we
still have this ritual
of running the Black antisemitism,
sort of cranking up the
Black antisemitism machine
and then the apologies and the learning,
and the triumphant redemption tour.
And it's to me, I don't,
I mean, I don't wanna sort of
lapse into the vernacular here
in answering what's a
very serious question,
but it's nuts that we have
not developed a phrase
like evangelical antisemitism, right?
Or Christian Zionist, Christian
Zionist antisemitism, right?
Like that's real in our world right now,
not only is it real, but
it's terrifyingly shaping
of our national politics.
I'm gonna, go ahead.
- Also, I think it's really interesting,
of course, I was thinking about kind of,
the sort of history and trajectory
of patterns of antisemitic thinking
amongst the Black community,
and I think what a lot
of people don't often address
is the fact that Black people
inherited a millennia old
system of preexisting,
Christian antisemitic
rhetoric, which many times,
is often present in the
antisemitic thinking
that is found in portions
of the Black community.
So we don't call it Christian,
we need to do something
about Christian antisemitism,
but God forbid should
a Black leader invoke
the image of Judas,
immediately that is apportioned
to his Blackness, and not
necessarily to his Christianity.
- Right, right.
And I wanna, let me throw one thing in
that maybe I shouldn't,
but I'm gonna go ahead and do it anyway.
Israel looms really large in
this contemporary conversation,
just to get back to Matt's question,
which is to say, you know,
one of the breaking points,
in the Black-Jewish relations
narrative of the late 1960s
is that many
African-Americans begin to see
their position in the United States
as having much more in
common with Palestinians
in the Middle East than
with white Jews in Israel.
That's obviously a real problem
for a lot of American Jews, right?
Now in our own moment, Christian Zionists,
who very often are starkly antisemitic
in some of the most
traditional, terrible ways,
they're Zionists, though, right?
They support the state of
Israel as the Jewish state.
And so they're off the
hook with a huge swath
of American Jewry, who still support
the idea of Israel as a Jewish state.
So the Israel question is really in this,
in some complicated ways
and has been, you know,
for Black people in the United
States as a kind of negative,
you know, sort of check
against them, right?
Because there's this sense
that develops in the late '60s,
early '70s, that Black
people are anti-Israel right?
And in our own moment, the
proponents of the most dangerous
antisemitism in the
United States, bar none,
are people who support Israel.
And so, we're in this very complicated
sort of religious,
racial, political moment.
- Great.
So a question about, you
know, I would say that,
both Blacks and Jews have this weight
of a very difficult
history looming over them.
I mean, both feel that they
were victims of unique forms
of oppression and rightly.
So we have slavery on the one hand,
and we have the Holocaust on the other.
And I think I'm wondering
if you can say anything
about this kind of almost
like an implicit sense
of competition among victims.
And does that play into the difficulties
of the Black-Jewish paradigm?
- I think it's interesting
that you expressed,
expressed it on the Jewish
side in terms of the Holocaust,
because I think for a lot of communal
and familial narratives
about the phenomenon
of Jewish suffering, it
often predates the Holocaust
and knowing and naming the nature
of that systemic oppression,
usually by the Russian Empire,
is an important part
of formulating exactly
what the narrative is that
connects Black people and Jews.
I believe you are talking
about a phenomenon
that is very colloquially
called the Oppression Olympics.
- Olympics, absolutely.
- It's said on Twitter
that we should get used
to the Oppressic Olympics,
because it's gonna be the only Olympics
that are gonna be
happening for a long time.
I...
I, Jeffrey, would you like to take that?
- I mean, I also, I just
happened to have this book
sitting right near me and I don't,
I don't know if you can see.
Toni Morrison's "Beloved,"
which came out in 1987
and I don't know who on the
call will remember this,
but there was a huge,
well, I won't say huge,
but there was a legible Jewish response,
negative response to the
book because of the epigraph.
And I'll read it, because it's short.
The first thing you read in the book
that Toni Morrison wrote
is, "60 million and more."
So simple, she's, opening the book,
she's clearly making this move
to try to get our attention
to the Middle Passage and putting a number
on the number of people
who perished as a result
of the Middle Passage.
And it's because she said 60,
and you people will have
to trust me on this,
if you haven't heard this before,
there was an outcry in certain corners
of the Jewish community
that she was trying
to sort of outdo the 6
million in a major scale,
right, by saying the 60 million.
And so this is like a real,
this is really structure and formation
in Black-Jewish relations is that Jews
always wanna keep, certain
Jews want to keep present
and I'll just say it,
because this is a particular
political concern of mine,
that to me, is the work
in our own time, of the
Anti-Defamation League,
right, which is involved
in a lot of business,
but one of the main things
they're involved with
is keeping present this idea
that Jews in the United States
live always, every day, an
incredibly fraught experience
and in doing so, they very
often are put in a position
of having to elbow out
African-American claims
to that same kind of status.
- Okay, I'm gonna go there,
and I'm going to bring
the discussion to what
we were talking about
right before we started,
and what I think is,
tragically, on a lot of
people's minds right now,
which is RBG.
And, you know, we're all, you know,
experiencing that loss right now.
But you know, it's an interesting thing,
that very term, RBG, is
arguably an appropriation
or not even arguably, an appropriation
from African-American culture.
And I'm wondering if, I know that you two,
I'm not really wondering,
I know that you two
have something to say
about the way that we,
she has been lionized in our,
in the culture right now, is being,
and whether that, and
what that is enabling,
and also maybe what that is repressing.
- Ever so briefly, I'd
like to address the fact
that giving the judge this moniker,
this kind of cutesy moniker
as a sort of campaign
of valorization is very
indicative of the fact
that there is a point in American history,
in contemporary history where valorization
was decided, was much more interesting
and much more easy to
do than civic action.
In a way, we could outsource
the kind of civic action
that we were supposed to be doing
to these kind of elevated actors.
If, I mean, Jeffrey, has had
kind of really interesting
and very multilayered things to say
around the construction of a concept
like The Notorious RBG.
- Yeah, I'm happy to jump
in at least briefly on that.
'Cause I've been tangling
with people on social media
for a couple of days about this.
I'm worried that I've lost my connection,
so I'm gonna try to reconnect.
Okay, I got it.
I'm okay, all right.
Okay, so just tell me in the chat box,
if you lose me, and my
internet connection's
being a little weird.
So the idea that you take
this jurist, this short,
white Jewish woman and
make a meme out of her
and put Christopher
Wallace, Notorious B.I.G.'s
crown on her, I can't help but
try to read it in the history
of the Jewish presence and minstrelsy.
I'm not putting this on
Ginsburg herself, obviously.
I don't think she had much to
do with her own memification.
Right?
This is people around her.
It was invented, originally,
by a Jewish NYU Law student
who then co-wrote the
book "Notorious RBG,"
the children's book.
And so this is a Jewish, it's
a white Jewish production
and it's impossible for
me not to see it as humor,
just sort of the putative humor in it.
as being in the distance
between the brilliant,
white jurist and the street
rapper from Brooklyn.
Now there are, I just wanna be fair,
there's plenty of people
who are saying like
no, it was honoring both of them.
It was saying that in their fields,
they were both, you know, tough talkers.
Like didn't get into the sort
of conventional expectations
and all that, but I'm
a historian, you know?
And I gotta read it in history
and there is this legible
history of Jewish people
pretending to be Black.
And it's a really important history,
and it's, I mean, it's
my whole first book.
Obviously I care about it,
this question of how Jews,
because exactly because of
their closeness to Black people
claimed a special ability
to write Black music,
to perform Black music,
to promote Black music.
And later on, when Jews
sort of stepped out
of the central role to be, you know,
the record label owners and
the producers and so on.
So there's like a history
here that I think's impossible
to ignore, when we think
about The Notorious RGB.
The conversation I've been
in, and it's been fascinating,
and particularly interesting to see
all of the African-American
people who have jumped in
to the conversation to
say, Oh, yeah, that's,
everyone knows that's
been bad for a long time.
And I wasn't aware, like I didn't,
I feel benighted 'cause I wasn't aware
that there was a whole
conversation already about it.
- Okay.
So, you know, a couple of
people have noted that,
or have wondered whether this,
the Black-Jewish relations paradigm,
is it only really something in the past?
Or can we talk about moments
or points of convergence today?
You know, one of them being, for instance,
that that Blacks and Jews are
two of the most loyal groups
within the Democratic party.
In fact, their voting
records are pretty similar,
for the most part.
And, you know, to try, we only
have a couple minutes left.
So I think this is gonna
be the last question,
but is there...
Are there moments of, of kind of,
are there positive things that
we might look towards today,
politically useful ways of thinking
about the Black-Jewish relationship today?
- Ever so briefly-
- Without whitewashing what's
wrong about it, but yeah.
- Of course.
Ever so briefly, I'd
like to address the fact
that the reason why we
even have the ability
to name check the people
who did take the effort
to align themselves with nascent movements
of racial equality is
because they showed up
in physical space.
They did not show up in rhetorical space.
They did not release a concept record
about what they thought their relationship
was to Black people.
They did not write an essay,
even though as an essayist,
I think it still is
important work to do that,
to get those ideas out into the world.
They showed up in physical American space,
an American space in which,
where they were supposed
to be in order to retain
the status quo was very
distinctly written out.
They crossed those boundaries,
they crossed the imaginary boundaries
of what the American Jewish-Black relation
was supposed to be, and they
entered into physical space
and they showed up on
behalf of Black people.
And I think as long as
you are trying to do that
to the best of your ability,
you will find yourself
answering this question, directly,
in time, and once again,
in American space.
- Great.
I mean, I have almost
nothing to add to that
other than, you know, if
you can join your union.
I'm just trying to think of literal,
street-level places
where African-Americans
and Jews might still come in contact
and the growing union
movement, and particularly,
teachers' unions, particularly
trying to bring together,
sort of main classroom teachers
with paraprofessional teachers,
there's gonna be some
really interesting ways
that I think Jews, in particular,
will be challenged to
imagine as I think Anthony
was just really hinting at,
imagining solidarity with Black people
that will mean Jews showing up for things
that might not immediately benefit them,
but that might be kind of just larger,
social justice achievements
that Jews care about,
or should care about.
- Right.
The Civil Rights Movement originally
was not an overdetermined phenomenon.
People did not know how
it was going to end.
- Right.
- Which makes the actions
of Jews in that particular period,
who were a part of that
movement, even more valorous
in my mind, because this was once again,
like a nascent movement.
There were not terms which
were dictated to the people
who were in this movement
in order to assure
that they were going
to join this movement.
We really do have these models,
and if we follow these models in space,
if we show up, like I said, once again,
we have answers to these questions.
- Okay, well I think we
have to leave it there.
It's 6:00.
Clearly, this conversation
could go on a lot longer
and fortunately it will.
And I encourage everyone to tune in
for our whole lecture series
this semester, which again,
you can find on the YPSA, YPSA website.
And my apologies to the
people who asked questions
that I didn't get to ask.
They were really fascinating questions.
And I thank the audience,
but let's all give
our special thanks to Jeff and Anthony.
One of the downsides of
the webinar format is
that they can't hear you, but
I will clap for everybody.
(clapping) So thank you very,
very much for this really,
really stimulating conversation, so.
- Thank you so much for having us.
- Thank you, really.
Thank you everybody for showing up.
Great to see your names, att least.
Really appreciate it.
- [Mauri] Okay.
- Thanks. Take care.